I have three daughters and three sons  Three Sons  when you're 18 get out  get out  now while you're out  better get one degree  two degrees before you come messing with  me  like I'm not just gonna be funding stuff  because you want to do it  I did to them like somebody did to me  when they turned 18 I went to the bank  because I spent a million dollars in one  day and the guy gave me a book The  dummies got to starting your own  business I gave them all the same book  and I said here you go you're a man now  make a decision but really I don't want  to come mess with me I need one or two  degrees not the lady is a little  different hey baby you can stay as long  as you want  I love you sweetheart no boys don't  worry about getting married  and you know the conversation I had with  my six children I said look we don't  need another basketball player your  daddy's crazy you don't need to be like  me